oui,
bien, donc il y a une sonde sat juste sur le
moniteur,
si vous la prenez et si vous la faites glisser
et la placez à côté de sa
main, cela devrait cliquer sur son doigt
[Musique]
une gamme de masques à oxygène différents donc
il devrait y avoir
un simple  un masque facial là-bas
et une autre
[Musique]
tout au long de la faculté de médecine, vous
savez, des patients agissant viennent faire des
scénarios cliniques particuliers, puis nous avons
eu une simulation vr qui est un peu comme
ça mais elle n'utilise pas réellement l'
espace réel, c'est juste un écran dans  devant
vos yeux, cela vous amène
au niveau supérieur où vous mélangez réellement
votre monde réel et votre patient holographique
en termes de médicaments et nous pouvons
réfléchir à celui qui se trouve
devant
nous utilisons la réalité étendue.
la technologie ainsi que
des scénarios de simulation pour former et enseigner à notre prochaine
génération de personnels de santé
d'une manière plus ciblée
et plus
conviviale.
Je ne dirais jamais que les médecins doivent
sortir des murs et arrêter de voir des
patients et d'arrêter de parler aux patients
et, en fin de compte, la simulation n'est pas le cas.  je vais
recréer tous les scénarios que vous allez
avoir et ces moments que vous
avez avec des patients où vous avez besoin d'un
très bon système de compétences en communication